hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice chess puzzle that was composed by
pal Benko when he was still a teenager I
think around 15 years old and I was just
well we don't usually show puzzles on
this channel sometimes we do there's no
rule about it and sometimes I feel like
showing a puddle sometimes I don't but
basically it's one once or twice a year
maybe yeah yeah maybe I'll show more
maybe I won't it really depends on how I
feel but I was trolling the internet the
other day as I usually do and I came
upon this tweak by a historian Olympia
Orkin saying that according to pub and
how a young Bobby Fischer lost two bets
when he tried to solve this composition
of his naturally I was very intrigued by
this tweet and of course I clicked on
the link and it takes you to the chess
history website where you can learn a
little bit more about the story behind
the disposal and yeah I will put a link
to it in the description below it will
be the first thing you see so you can
check it out yourself and also I will I
will put a link to a mr. Olympia Wilkins
profile on Twitter so you can follow him
if you are interested in increasing your
vast knowledge on a daily basis as he
will quite often post very interesting
things regarding chess now it's not that
chess chess knowledge is located on
Twitter but a lot of people use Twitter
especially pretty much older all the
modern top players and you will learn a
lot of stuff as maybe can be pointed
towards in the direction of vast
knowledge and check it out there like in
this case the chess history website
Albania for those of you who are maybe
lazy to click on the link I will mention
the story briefly it was during the 1968
Lugano Olympiad in Switzerland Bobby
Fischer was spectating the event and the
Soviet team really crushed the field
they came with Dignam Petrosyan Boris
Spassky Viktor Korchnoi effing Geller
laughs Allah gave skin and vasily
smyslov they crushed the field with
eight and a half point lead
so just complete Soviet domination but
regarding this position here o Benko
asked Bobby Fischer well here he said to
him I will bet you that you cannot solve
this puzzle in half an hour
and Fischer of course it was the 1968
Fischer so the
very strong Bobby Fischer the 1970 palm
of the America tournament where his
incredible Street begins is only two
years from this moment here and of
course Bobby was very interested and he
said okay let's let's have the position
and I will solve it in half an hour and
after the half an hour mark expired
Bobby was still unable to solve the
puzzle and he demanded that the solution
be presented to him now I will show you
the solution maybe if you don't want to
see it maybe if you really enjoy the
position and the story behind it maybe
you just want to you know keep it for
herself without knowing the solution
maybe you can have it you know on your
table somewhere at home and then just
enjoy it every day if you don't want to
know the solution or you can you know
but it's better maybe to do it that way
but if you're just interested in the
solution then you can also show to your
friends in the library and the bar and
it's just a very nice idea
so for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show here it is this is the
solution pal Benko presented the Bobby
Bishop the c4
there is only one solution and that's
the other part of the story that's it
there is only one solution after Bishop
to c4 Black has two options you can
either go king e5 or King f5 all of the
other squares are taken by the Queen by
the bishop by Deirdre Bishop and the
Queen controls the entire D file so here
if you go King to the f5 then the idea
is next you will get Queen to h5 check
and after the King moves you will for
example go King to f6 then you get Queen
to g5 mate as now the Queen slices this
way the bishop slices this way and the
King has no squares you can see that the
Queen guards discourse as well on the
other hand after Queen to h5 check if
the King goes to e4 then it's just Queen
to d5 check again
Queen slices this way Bishop slices this
way covering the dark squares and well
all of the squares are nicely covered
the King has nowhere to go so that's one
way after King to f5 another idea after
king the King to f5 is that you can play
queen h5 check but also Quinta f3 check
seems like a possum
idea for example now if King to g6 now
after King to g6 you will play Queen to
f7 and this is again mate because again
the dark square Bishop covers the dark
squares and well you just slice all of
the all of the squares here and on the
other hand after Queen to f3 check if
you go somewhere else for example King
the e5 then you get the Queen to f4 mate
again it's the same formation Queen
covers these squares and the bishop
slices this diagonal here it's a very
interesting puzzle because sometimes you
will find yourself in a position where
you can maybe deliver mate on the board
and you will know that for example a
bishop and queen for you know two
squares apart deliver mate if the Queen
checks the King this this is made so
that's if the King goes King to f5 but
also after Bishop to c4 the king can go
kink the e5 and then it's a different
mate it's Queen to d5 check King has to
go to f6 and now it's Queen to g5 may
meet again the same idea
Bishop slices over this way there is one
possibility that doesn't work but it's
very interesting I thought it works when
I was looking at the position after King
d5 I thought it was Queen d7
I usually don't think that the solution
involves such brute checks so I thought
it was Queen d7 and then after the King
goes to e4 then of course you deliver
Queen to d5 mate the problem is after
this
well Queen to d7 move you can go King to
f6 and now there is no mate you could
deliver mate if the Queen could come to
g5 but the Queen cannot come to g5 you
can deliver Queen to f7 check but then
King e5 the King escapes and well that's
three moves you don't have four moves so
yeah maybe I even forgot to mention that
yeah it's mate in three you had to find
mate in three so sorry if I if I miss
that but you always when when someone
asks you to solve the position it means
find find the solution in the least
possible number of moves so if you can
mate in three then that's the solution
even though you can find obviously me
in 50 so sorry about not mentioning that
but you know solving the position means
in this case delivering mate so yeah
probably should have mentioned that but
IIIi hope it works either way
but that's the point after this Bishop
to c4 Bishop Fisher saw the solution and
then he bet pal Benko that Fisher can
find another solution not just the
Bishop c4 one he was convinced that
there was a different winning move where
you can deliver mate in three but there
is no such such mate and the bet was
that Fisher can study the position
overnight and then he would present
Benko with a solution the other day so
as the story goes Fisher tried to solve
it for the entire night and he failed
but yeah there is another solution only
it's a meeting force so that doesn't
count
you need a mate in three the another
solution would involve for example Queen
to b6 check and then King to f5 Bishop
to d3 check King to g4 now comes Queen
to f4 check King h3 and now Bishop to f1
check this is one such idea but this is
mating four and we need the shortest
solution possible so those were the two
bets that fish were lost I don't know if
they actually bet in something like for
example a bag of gold or something
I don't think so as it was pray it would
probably be presented in in a power bank
of stories and it was probably it would
probably be written in the chess history
website I think it was more of a more of
an honor typed bet where Bobby just
couldn't solve it and venko was very
happy and Banquo was very impressed
himself that he was able to give such a
challenge to Bobby Fischer with a
composition that a banco composed when
he would he was 15 years old so really
an awesome puzzle I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you can impress a lot of
your you know friends at the library
ended the bar with this a wonderful
composition and then you can just tell
them you know you're welcome to try and
solve it but you know Bobby Fischer
couldn't do it in half an hour but you
know you're more than welcome to
do it so that's the puzzle I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Tony
Moore guitar and Dirk Elsevier's for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate that as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the capablanca saga we still
have to show banco versus a banco versus
tile in the chorus all candidates from
in 1962 and of course as usual I will be
checking up on your suggestions so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day